Republicans are already
signaling their intent
to stonewall
President Biden's agenda
while dismissing the need
for an impeachment trial
for former President Trump.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
Our political system
is currently overloaded
way beyond its capacity.
It's like a power strip with
way too many things plugged in.
We already got the TV, Roku,
printer, modem,
iPad, InstaPod,
immersion blender,
Christmas tree, and toaster
plugged in,
and now we need to find room
for the sleep-apnea machine.
And because I live in New York,
there's only one other outlet,
and it was drywalled over
during
the Coolidge administration,
on top of a deadly pandemic
that has overwhelmed hospitals,
an unprecedented
economic collapse
that has plunged millions
into joblessness
and food scarcity and
a botched vaccine rollout
that has states saying they're
about to run out of doses,
we also have a violent
authoritarian movement
that tried to
overthrow democracy,
led by a former president
facing an impeachment trial
for, um --
What was it for, again?
-There will be a trial,
and when that trial ends,
Senators will have to decide
if they believe
Donald John Trump
incited the erection --
insurrection against
the United States.
-Well, if erection
is the charge,
then we certainly
don't want him to beat it.
-♪ Yeah ♪
[ Laughter ]
-And they thought we were gonna
run out of material.
They should do
a "CSI: Mar-a-Lago."
Shut up!
[ Laughter ]
Who needs you
rolling your eyes at me?
[ Laughter ]
The only bummer
about Schumer's gaffe was
it happened on a Friday,
when we were dark,
so the only person I could tell
my "beat it" joke to
was my wife,
but she bought
noise-canceling headphones
on our honeymoon
seven years ago.
Anyway, today the White House
officially sent --
excuse me -- today
the House officially sent --
still not as bad as
"erection"/"insurrection."
[ Laughter ]
But a reminder,
we all make mistakes, Chuck.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, today the House
officially sent
its article of impeachment
over to the Senate,
setting up a trial in two weeks.
-The Historic second impeachment
of President Trump
that takes a big step forward.
The one article
brought against him,
incitement of insurrection,
will be delivered to the Senate.
That triggers a Senate trial,
now set to begin
in about two weeks.
-Monday is that day
that Pelosi and the House
will formally transmit
that one article of impeachmemt
to the Senate,
kicking off Tuesday
as the day where Senators
will be sworn in
as members of the trial.
But then it will be
another two weeks
until we see that trial
formally begin.
McConnell actually arguing
he actually wanted three weeks
so that the president
could actually begin
to create his defense team
and also strengthen his argument
against impeachment.
-So, Trump's lawyers
will have two weeks
to prepare for their defense,
which I guess will be --
what? -- when he told the
violent mob of unhinged rioters
to march down to the Capitol
and fight to stop Democrats
from stealing the election,
he was joking?
"Your Honor, when he whipped the
insurrectionists into a frenzy,
he was being sarcastic.
That's why he turned
to the camera,
and made
a freeze-frame sitcom face,
the classic Mr. Roper Defense.
Not to be confused
with Furley's Gambit.
Or maybe they'll say
it was a different guy.
"Ya got the wrong Donald Trump.
You want this guy."
-You have an opportunity today!
You can be a hero,
or you can be a zero!
-This is like where you're
in a conference room
at a Radisson,
listening to a life coach
tell you how to pick up women.
"You can be a hero,
or you can be a zero!
You could be a single guy,
or you can be the mingle guy!
You can be a dud and a chump,
or you can be a stud on a stump!
Yeah, I posed for that picture!"
[ Laughter ]
Don Jr. has so much confidence
onstage.
But I bet if you'd
try to find him after,
and tell him he did a great job,
he'll be leaning against
the wall, smoking and crying.
"Do you think my dad just narked
me out to the feds?!"
Of course, Trump has had
a little trouble
assembling a defense team
for his impeachment,
because his usual lawyer is busy
getting sued
for over a billion dollars.
-"The New York Times" reports
that Dominion Voting Systems
has filed a defamation lawsuit
this morning
against Rudy Giuliani.
According to the paper,
the 107-page lawsuit
accuses Mr. Giuliani
of carrying out
a viral disinformation campaign
about Dominion,
made up of demonstrably false
allegations,
in part, to enrich himself
through legal fees
and his podcast.
The suit seeks damages of
more than $1.3 billion.
-It's funny, if you sue someone
for a billion dollars,
it sound like a joke.
But when you sue them
for $1.3 billion,
you start to think, "Oh, they
might have some evidence."
What are you gonna do,
sue me for a billion dollars?
Oh, $1.3 billion?
What do they know?"
[ Laughter ]
And $1.3 billion from Rudy?!
Good thing
vampires are immortal,
because he'll have work
the rest of his life
to pay that off.
I mean, he doesn't have
any money.
This poor man
doesn't have any money.
Do you remember how he couldn't
even afford hair dye
and just rubbed
a typewriter ribbon on his head?
Plus, he's probably still
playing alimony to his cousin.
[ Laughter ]
Trump reportedly
won't even pay Rudy
for all those trips he made
across the country,
lying to steal the election,
and I'm betting
Trump made him fly cheap.
Rudy probably had to buy
a wing seat on Spirit Airlines.
[ Lisping ] I talk like this
because my teeth
are still full of bugs.
[ Normal voice ] Of course,
Trump isn't actually defending
--
excuse me -- depending on --
I'm really Schumer-ing it up.
[ Laughter ]
Chuck Schumer --
Chuck Schumer cursed me.
Now who is laughing?
-♪ Yeah ♪
[ Laughter ]
I love when we cut out right
before we have to pay The Who.
[ Laughter ]
You know who owns
the publishing for The Who?
Ol' Rolex Wally.
-♪ Yeah ♪
-Three seconds.
We don't owe you a dime!
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Trump isn't actually
depending on a real defense
of his actions, because they're
obviously indefensible.
I'm no lawyer,
but it's pretty obvious
he tried to commit sedition,
he fomented
a violent insurrection
to stop the lawful counting
of electoral votes,
nearly installed a crony
at the Department of Justice
to overturn the results,
and tried to bully
the Secretary of State
in Georgia
to commit election fraud.
What Trump is
really depending on
is servile, morally bankrupt
Republicans falling in line.
And judging from comments
they made over the weekend,
the GOP is fully on board.
-This election was not stolen.
Do you accept that fact?
-Well, what I would say is
that the debate
over whether or not
there was fraud should occur.
-The Department of Justice,
led by William Barr,
said there is no widespread
evidence of fraud.
Can't you just say the words
that the election
was not stolen?
-What I would suggest is --
What I would suggest is
that if we want greater
confidence in our elections --
and 75% of Republicans
agree with me --
is that we do need to look
at election integrity.
-If you listen to what the
president said at the rally,
he said,
"Demonstrate peacefully."
And then I got a question later
about whether
did he incite them.
I also think everybody
across this country
has some responsibility.
-I think the trial is stupid.
I think it's counterproductive.
I think this is gonna be
really bad for the country.
It's going take us --
Not just is it going to
keep us from focusing
on really important things,
but it's also just going to
stir it up even more.
-Man, they're throwing
everything at the wall --
impeachment
will stir up the country;
the election was stolen;
we all bear some responsibility.
It's like getting pulled over
with a giant plume
of marijuana smoke in the car
and telling the cop,
"I think it's the exhaust pipe.
It is legal in several states.
And I only started smoking
when you pulled me over,
because that gave me
severe anxiety."
Also, Marco, honestly,
do you have any shame at all?
You called Trump
an embarrassment
and a con man
and implied in public
that he had a tiny [Bleep].
But now you're
calling impeachment stupid?
Also, you famously doinked a kid
in the head with a football.
You don't get to call anything
stupid after that, ever.
And you think impeachment
would stir up the country?
It's already stirred.
This is what you call "stirred."
You guys already
did the stirring.
You don't get to pretend
everything is just fine now.
Violent seditionists
and white supremacists
and militia members
stormed the Capitol building
and tried
to overthrow democracy.
We have to
do something about that
so it doesn't happen again.
Instead, Republican leaders
are talking about Trump's base
the way park rangers talk
about bears on a campground.
"Don't make eye contact,
move away slowly,
and if worse comes to worse,
let them eat your hot dogs.
They're just hot dogs."
So Republicans have already
made it clear
they refuse
to hold Trump accountable
for inciting an insurrection
or do anything at all
about the violent
authoritarian movement
they've cultivated,
not to mention the pandemic,
vaccine rollout,
and economic crisis.
Suffice it to say, just because
Joe Biden is president now
doesn't mean
things are normal again.
They're not.
At this point,
when I check my phone
in the morning,
I just have one news alert
from CNN
that says,
"Breaking: everything."
Nearly a million people have
recently filed for unemployment,
thousands are dying a day,
and the one thing
that could be a silver bullet,
distribution of the vaccine,
was left in disarray
by the last administration.
In fact, millions of doses
are reportedly missing,
and no one knows why
or where they are.
For all we know, Trump
left the White House
with a bunch of vials
stuffed in his coat,
and now he's selling them
at the Mar-a-Lago buffet.
I don't even know
where to begin
when I check the news
in the morning.
I open my "New York Times" app,
and all the headlines are bad,
so I check
"The Washington Post" app,
and all the headlines are bad.
And then I check the
"Pittsburgh Post-Gazette" app,
and the Steelers
are still out of the playoff.
Which reminds me, last week,
after Ted Cruz said
President Biden was choosing
the people of Paris
over the people of Pittsburgh,
I favorably compared
my father's hometown of
Pittsburgh to Paris,
remarking that,
unlike Pittsburgh,
Paris doesn't have an incline.
Well, some French viewers
were quick to point out
that Paris does, in fact,
have an incline, or funicular,
in Montmartre.
So I would like to retract
that statement.
I also called Ted Cruz a jagoff,
and I'd like to retract that,
but only so that I can say it
again for the first time.
Ted Cruz, you're a jagoff.
On top of everything else
that's going on right now,
there are also the crises
that preceded Trump,
like our healthcare crisis,
the climate crisis,
voter suppression,
structural inequality
and institutional racism,
not to mention the conditions
that nearly allowed Trump
to remain in office
or steal the election,
despite winning
7 million fewer votes.
We need mechanisms in place
for bold systemic change
and immediate relief
for suffering Americans,
which is why
the Biden administration
has started by offering a plan
to provide billions of dollars
for vaccine distribution,
increased unemployment benefits,
direct payments,
and a $15 minimum wage,
among other things.
Republicans meanwhile
have responded by announcing
their opposition to it.
-President Joe Biden's proposal
to boost the U.S. economy
and efforts to fight
the COVID-19 pandemic
is facing
some Republican opposition.
-While Biden is pushing
for Republican and Democratic
lawmakers
to work toward an agreement,
there's some criticism
from the GOP.
-Multiple
Congressional Republicans,
from Senator Pat Toomey
to Congressman Kevin Brady,
top Republican on the House
Ways and Means Committee,
have public panned Biden's
proposal as a nonstarter.
-Republican Senator
Susan Collins,
who was on the call,
has reservations,
writing in a statement,
"It seems premature
to be considering a package
of this size and scope."
-I'm sorry, Susan Collins, it's
premature?
You want to wait a little longer
and see how much worse
things can get?
This is like if the Steelers
waited a couple more weeks
to find a running game.
Okay.
Okay, now I get why my wife
bought those headphones.
I just heard it.
I just heard it
for the first time.
Seriously, when would be
the right time
to maybe start thinking
about considering
possibly doing something
eventually
about the highly infectious
virus rapidly spreading
across the country,
overwhelming hospitals,
and forcing millions
out of work?
When would be
a good time for you?
Getting these people
to do something
about a national crisis is like
getting Verizon to come
set up your Fios.
"We could pencil you in
sometime between 9:00 a.m.
and 6:00 p.m. on Saturday,
March 37, 2045.
Would that work?
Can you give us your address
to the technician can go
to a different house?"
The Republican Party
has learned nothing,
and it has not changed.
It's still the party
that elected Trump
and stood by him
as he attempted
to foment sedition.
It's the same party
that spent eight years
stonewalling
President Obama's agenda.
And now, even after a historic,
resounding defeat
after losing the House,
the Senate, and the presidency,
Republicans are still standing
in the way of urgent relief,
systemic change,
and accountability
amid multiple
simultaneous crises.
If you're asking yourself
what their motivation is,
it's possible that they're...
-Stupid.
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
And they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.